et maintenant jean philippe dugoin
clément qui aimait rudy 2006 bonsoir à
vous merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france ce soir donc un
commentaire sur la victoire de valérie
pécresse en ile de france vous êtes
satisfait bonsoir oui c'est une très
belle victoire je rappelle que nous
gagnons avec un score plus élevé qu il y
a cinq ans alors que nous sommes en
cadres angulaire il ya cinq ans une
triangulaire nous sommes sur une des
régions qui est les plus difficiles pour
la droite et le centre-droit de sa
mission de région qui sociologiquement
est plutôt de gauche qui a une
sociologie sur une partie de son
territoire qui est extrêmement relm et
donc le résultat que nous enregistrons
ce soir avec la majorité sortante de
valérie pécresse est le résultat d'une
union extrêmement large et puis c'est le
résultat d'un bilan c'est le résultat
d'une équipe régionale qui a travaillé
qui a porté des dossiers d'une région
qui a été incarné qui a connu une
nouvelle dynamique et ça montre bien
également et je crois que c'est très
important on le voit toutes les régions
de france métropolitaine ont maintenu
leur confiance aux exécutifs
on est sur une élection qui avant tout
apporte un satisfecit à des majorités
qui ont travaillé c'est le cas en
ile-de-france alors un satisfecit en
tout cas que beaucoup d'observateurs
politiques pourraient vous reprocher au
regard du taux d'abstention record 66%
l'estimation à 20 heures c'est certes un
petit peu mieux qu'au premier tour avec
un 66 7%
l'abstention quand on est à 66 %
d'abstention absolument personne ne peut
se réjouir après à savoir si plus de
participation aurait changer tel ou tel
scrutin
bon c'est la première fois que j'entends
le front national se plaindre
d'abstention quant aux quant à la
république en marche la réalité c'est
que le gouvernement a fait tout ce qu'il
pouvait pour promouvoir cette abstention
ce soit par une absence de communication
institutionnelle total sur ces élections
par le fait que les deux chambres
maintiennent leurs travaux pendant la
période de campagne électorale ce qui
est du jamais vu dans l'histoire de la
république que les professions de foi
les bulletins de vote n'arrive pas le
choix des dates la fête des pères et ce
week-end qui sont des dates de départs
en vacances
c'est donc très bien aujourd'hui on ne
peut que regretter cette abstention trop
forte
on ne peut que tout se dire que ça pose
des problèmes de fond pour notre système
et notre démocratie
après très honnêtement si on avait été à
5 10 15 % de votants en plus
est-ce qu'on aurait eu les mêmes
résultats amplifier des résultats
inversés avec des si on mettrait paris
en bouteille les exécutifs qui ont été
élus ont été légitimement je note qu'il
ya des écarts extrêmement importants qui
ont pu être creusé
donc voilà mais ce problème de
l'abstention qui globalement
tendanciellement grandi dans notre pays
depuis une trentaine d'années maintenant
est un problème majeur
on est en train de glisser petit à petit
sur beaucoup de thèmes sur une
démocratie à l'amérique tellement vous
l'interprétez ce problème dans mois jean
philippe dugoin clément comment vous
interpréter ce problème est-ce que c'est
défiance de la démocratie vis-à-vis de
la démocratie une défiance vis-à-vis de
la classe politique est finalement
encore une fois est-ce que ces résultats
ils ne sont pas visés il ya plusieurs
facteurs
il ya plusieurs facteurs il ya des
facteurs conjoncturels je les ai cité
est globalement il ya deux facteurs
lourds pour moi si on est dans un pays
qui est beaucoup trop complexe
on a un nombre de strates un nombre de
structures qui font que ça devient
illisible pour les citoyens qui ne
savent pas qui fait quoi qui sert à quoi
et très objectivement si vous demandez à
des gens dans la rue les compétences des
régions des départements qui pourtant
sont des compétences essentielles dans
la vie quotidienne beaucoup plus souvent
qu'un certain nombre de compétences
nationales les gens ne les connaissent
pas parce qu'on a fait un pays pro
compliqué moi je pense qu'on doit
simplifier on doit revenir à des
institutions qui soit visible
et puis la deuxième chose c'est qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une défiance de beaucoup de
citoyens par rapport au pouvoir
politique nationale et que cette
défiance sur le pouvoir politique
nationale ça génère de l'abstention ça
génère du rejet ça génère du
mécontentement
ce qui est très curieux c'est que cette
défiance vis-à-vis du national on ne le
retrouve pas électoralement sur les
scrutins locaux qu'ils soient municipaux
ou régionaux j'en veux pour preuve
l'absence totale du rassemblement
national et de la reine
sur ce scrutin justement travail est
fait soufflé les leaf locaux municipal
n'y a pas de progression et c'est la
même chose aux régionales
un mot sur les sondages commandés par à
l'ailé les médias est justement le
traitement de de ces élections le
traitement médiatique
quel bilan vous faites les sondages
nommer les sondages c'est un scandale
absolu refasse a fait 15 ans que de
toute façon les sondages sont plantés
sur absolument toutes les élections en
commençant par les présidentielles mais
si on se remet quinze jours en arrière
on nous annonce et le rassemblement
national en tête au premier tour dans
sept à huit régions ya une seule région
où le rassemblement national a été en
tête c'est paca et on ne donnait cinq
régions qu'il pouvait basculer au bout
de course aucune région nord- a basculé
et ce qui est d'ailleurs extrêmement
amusant c'est que ou curieux ou marquant
c'est la seule région le rassemblement
national arrive en deuxième position
avec un véritablement bon score c'est la
région paca et le candidat du
rassemblement national
c'est un élu qui a un ancrage local sur
toutes les autres régions on a des élus
qui font de l'élection nationale qui ne
parle pas des problèmes des habitants
des régions
si je prends monsieur bardella en ile de
france ça a été un des élus régionaux
les moins présents pendant l'ancienne
mandature son sujet était de savoir s'il
était candidat au grand hôtel dans les
hautes france ou en ile de france il
aurait fait exactement la même question
dans la même campagne dans une autre
région et je pense aussi à un moment
quand on est candidat à une élection
régionale qu on doit parler de la région
parce que c'est justement 106 de la
confédération nationale c'est se moquer
des électeurs justement vu le taux
d'abstention record est ce que les
français ont conscience du rôle des
présidents de région aujourd'hui est-ce
que c'est président de région car elle
pouvoir noës vie politique française il
y a un pouvoir des régions et des
départements d'ailleurs ce qui est des
départementales qui est absolument
colossal aujourd'hui mais qui est
inconnu de la part des français parce
qu'on est on a trop de strates on a trop
de structures le pays est trop complexe
les régions pourtant au quotidien ils
sont présentes les régions c'est ce qui
va gérer les lycées c'est ce qui va
gérer les transports
c'est ce qui va gérer l'aménagement du
territoire c'est où est ce qu'on
construit ou qu'on ne construit pas
comme on développe les choses
région c'est le soutient le
développement économique et la formation
c'est des compétences qui tous les jours
concerne les français mais le pays est
tellement complexe que très
objectivement les gens ne peuvent pas le
savoir il faut qu'on simplifie nos
institutions
je crois que c'est quelque chose
d'absolument fondamentale est que les
élus obtiennent des résultats pour
regagner de la confiance de la part des
citoyens parce que xavier bertrand est
le plus à même à mener la droite au
pouvoir en 2001 dup
il fait partie de ceux qui auront un
rôle à jouer et qui peuvent prétendre à
porter les couleurs de la droite et du
centre
nous ne pourrons échapper aux duels que
nous annoncent les sondages marc fassi
c'est avec la même réussite que les
sondages des élections régionales
mais nous ne pourrons échapper au duel
macron le pen que si la famille de
centre-droit et de droite arrive à se
réunir on va avoir un travail à faire on
a la chance d'avoir plusieurs
personnalités plusieurs visages ils
peuvent porter nos couleurs ce qui est
important c'est d'être unis parce que
faut être très clair
la division qu est le rassemblement
permet d'ouvrir des portes permet
d'avancer permet de gagner c'est le
travail qu'on va porter pendant les
prochains mois vous avez entendu notre
reporter un adage abderrazak visiblement
ce pour l'union c'est mal parti puisque
apparemment xavier bertrand à entendre
notre reporter ne souhaite pas de
primaires à droite est l'un des
enseignements de ces élections c'est
qu'il ya quand même trois
présidentiables potentiels au sein de l
air aujourd'hui xavier bertrand valérie
pécresse et laurent wauquiez aussi oui
les primaires ne sont pas la garantie de
l'union au fait si on veut prendre
l'exemple des primaires de gauche et
droite des dernières présidentielles
elles ont montré que toute façon les
engagements pris par l'ensemble des
candidats aux primaires n'était pas
tenue et qu'elle ne garantissait pas de
ne pas avoir de primaire de fête au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle les primaires c'est un
choix d'organisation
je suis pas forcément convaincu que ce
soit le seul où le meilleur mais la
primaire ne garantit pas une unicité de
candidature la problématique qui va se
poser très clairement pour ce pays si on
veut échapper aux duels le pen macron
est ce qu'on est capable d'avoir un
candidat l'union
de droite et de centre-droit donc à
défaut de primaires un accord c'est ça
ça peut être un accord savez on va avoir
des semaines qui vont venir avec déjà
des exécutifs régionaux qui vont se
réinstaller qu'ils vont recommencer à
travailler c'est quelque chose
d'important
et puis l'ensemble des candidats
potentiels chacun avec leurs qualités
vont être amenés à discuter avec les
formations politiques avec leurs
challengers mais pour essayer de trouver
la meilleure formule est la meilleure
formule c'est celle qui nous permettra
d'avancer unis et de gagner je veux dire
on arrivait à le faire dans toutes les
régions qu'on a remporté en
ile-de-france dans les hauts de france
en normandie en auvergne en paca dans le
grand test dans toutes ces régions là où
on avait également votre plusieurs
visages potentiel on a réussi à avancer
unis et on a gagné
eh bien c'est ce que nous allons faire
pour l'année prochaine merci à vous jean
philippe dugoin clément maire udi de
mennecy